à présent une chanson à succès auquel
les jeunes font un très grand succès
d'ailleurs ces belles elles belle femme
blonde françois accompagné par les
gameplay
long terme existants je te vois sortir
le soir à ton âge il ya des choses qu'un
garçon dos à voir les filles tu sais
méfie toi
c'est parce que tu crois sont toutes
belles de jour
bébel comme l'avouent
elle te rendre fou de joie fou de
douleur mec pas moi plus fous de jour en
jour
puis des filles de plus en plus
vent rentre
peut être même qu'à ça riou figeac en
fait tu en auras plus tant des rares et
plus tu n'entendras
les mamans tout souviendra que ton vieux
père d'isère sont vingt belles belles
comme le dessus
belle maman
la boue
elle rend fou de joie
mais
le jour en jour
un jour enfin la véracité de mon père
qui pourra plus parler
avec les verts ou saisir le pire elle
avait hier mais tu t'en vas là le vrai
bonheur on se doute donc
la
mer est belle comme eux
l'amour
somme je dis à ta maman tu lui en
embrassant du fbi belle cave au dessus
même une belle gamme où l'amour
benamour